hello my name is chair peleg and this is
the talk about lower bound and
stabilizer rank this is based on a joint
work with amil spielke and ben livolk
one of the most interesting open
problems in theoretical computer science
now and then it's the question of are
quantum computers more powerful powerful
than classical computers
and the widely believed answer is that
yes
quantum er
gives more computational power to to
computers and we have some evidence that
support this assumption
so the first is shows algorithm that a
factors number using quantum computers
efficiently which is the thing that we
do not know how to do
in
classical computers efficiently and this
is due to shore in 97
we have oracle and black box operations
uh between uh quantum computers and
classical computers due some examples
are simone 97 bernstein bazalgani from
1997 and rostall from 2019
we have a quantum computers have
advantage in sampling problems due to
our onsen and on kipo in 2013
and we have some separation for loaded
circuits for example due to bravi
gosseter konig from 2018 and was
this means that there are problems that
load that squanting circuits can solve
but low depth
classical circuits cannot solve
but uh
we also know that p is a sub subset of b
q p which is contained in p space
so because we do not know how to
separate p from p space we do not
believe that unconditional separation
is feasible in the near future and it
seems quite difficult to prove
so
what can we do in the meantime
we have some techniques that
shows a simulation of quantum computers
using classical computers so can we
prove that these specific simulation
techniques do not work
that means that there are some quantum
computation that they cannot
uh
simulate efficiently
so this is the main uh question that we
are interesting here here so just a bit
of notation qubits are unit vectors in
the in of dimension two over the complex
field
these are the notations
these are called pure uh qubits
and a state of basic of the system is
just a tensor product of n cubits so
it's a vector of dimension 2 to the n
over the complex field
the law of the universe says that we can
apply any unitary linear transformation
and then measure so
this is a circuit it
gets its nq bits as input apply some
unitary operations and finally it
measures
so as i mentioned
the load of the universe says that we
can apply any a unitary transformation
but if we want to bound the fanning of
our gates
we can allow all unitary transformation
on up to two qubits
so this is a standout gate set
and there is a fact that uh
there is a finite universal gate that
can approximate every general a quantum
computation on up to two qubits that
uses unitary operation and of the two
qubits and this finite universal gate
set consists of the following four
metrics
so they are denoted the first three are
denoted c note h and s
and they generate a group that is called
the clifford groups and these are what
we call clifford gates
and the
and the fourth one is t or the pi over
eighth grade gate and this gate is not
in the clifford group
effect by israel young and trump
2000 says
that the t gates can be pushed to the
inputs this is very similarly similar to
how we push negation to the to the input
when we deal with classical
circuits
so here if you have a circuits of size s
that use both clifford and t gates and
get n
qubits as input
you can
simulate you can replace it with a
quantum circuit that use only clifford
gate and its size is polynomial in s
but
as inputs it get all the n cubit as the
generals at the previous circuit but
also an ample supply of a magic state we
call h h is
essentially applying
the
matrix t
or um
over the
zero cubit and then applying some clip
of the cliff operation so this magic
state is
is uh if you get an ample supply supply
of it you can
compute any
any quantum
computation
and this magic state is as written here
um
cosine pi over pi over n times the zero
cube plus sine pi over a times the one
qubit so this is what we call the magic
state it's a fixed state
and we will use this name
a theorem by gotesman and kneel said
that clifford circuits and classical
input can be efficiently stimulated
using classical computer
this is still due to the fact that the
state of the
of the circuit is always a stabilization
state and such state can be repaired
represented and updated efficiently
using standard computations so if we
apply a clifford operation on a
stabilizer state we can update it and
and store the relevant data using
classical concrete
that's a corollary that if the n stanza
powered power of the magic state
can be represented as a small linear
combination of stabilizer states
then every classical computer can be
efficiently stimulated
because
if that's all we can uh
compute polynomially many
um
stabilizer states and apply the clifford
circuit on a stabilizer state which we
know that we can do and update and just
apply the linear combination before we
measure
so
this is an important color correlation
this motivates the following definition
of what we call a stabilizer ring so for
example quantum state psi we define here
psi
to be the minimum r such that psi can be
represented as a linear combination of
alpha stabilizer any our stabilizer
space
and
because we work with approximation a lot
it we also need to find the approximate
stabilizer range and
by that we we denote it by heat delta of
psi
and by that we look at all the
states that are contained in the l2 norm
valve of radius delta around
side
and ask what is the minimal
stabilizer state
stabilizer rank of any state in the
world and this is the approximated
stabilizer
rank of
site
so some known results or bounds on the
stabilizer range
and we are mainly interested on the
stabilizer on bounding the stabilizer
rank of this the nth power of the magic
states
so there is a lower bound of square root
of n
due to bravi smith and smalling from
2016.
there is an upper bound of two to the
alpha n where alpha is log three over
four
due to kasim pashian gossett from 2021
and
uh this is the
the last result in the line of work that
improves alpha and
and this is the best known upper bound
that we know of and we also note that
the
the
stabilizer rank of the
n tensor power of the magic state is
superpolynomial unless p equals np this
is due to huang newman and segedy from
2020
we know that the stabilizer rank is
indeed exponential assuming the
exponential time hypothesis due to
morime timaki from 2019
and
hns again
and we know that the stabilizer rank is
exponential if the coefficients that we
use in the linear
uh
combinations are small so
the stabilizer rank is the minimal r
such that
psi can be represented as a linear
combination of r stabilizer state so if
the coefficients in the linear
combination are small or bounded
we can prove that the stabilizer rank of
this magic state that we are interested
in is uh exponential and due to bss 20
in 2016 and bravi gossip in 2016 as well
and this is a
follows from some correlation balance
between stabilizers that states and the
magic state
and in this work we give a linear lower
bound for the stabilizer rank
of the magic state
the nth power the nth tensor power of
the magic state and we give
a
lower bound of square rooted and over
lower logan
for the delta approximation stabilizer
rank
of
the magic state
and this is so for any delta which is
sufficiently small from smaller than
some constant
and this is the first such lower bound
there is an equivalent definition for
stabilization states due to the gina de
moore and vandanes and they prove the
following so a quantum state psi is a
stabilizer state if and only if
psy has the following representation
so just to explain the notation when we
have a binary string x we can define an
associated quantum state by tensoring
the bases uh
qubits according to the values of the
binary string so wherever we see zero
with tensor with the zero qubit and
wherever we see one with tensor with the
one qubit
and
this is equivalent to two to indexing
the two to the n coordinates that we
have in our uh
vector space each of them
uh according to a binary string so this
is equivalent and therefore this is a
basis of c2 to the n
and a stabilizer and state is a
stabilizer state if it's a
representation in this basis is the
following so it only does it supports on
only on only indexing corresponding to
some alpha in space alpha in subspaces
of f 2 to the n
so
we allow the non-zero coefficients to be
only vectors that are in some offering
subspace a
and the coefficients themselves
are of the form i to the l my
minus 1 to the q
where
l is a linear form a linear function
over f2 and q is a quadratic function
over f2 so we have this
special basis which is just the standard
basis
and
we allow the support of our state to be
some alpha in sub-space and the
coefficient of each
vector
a basis element is i to the l minus 1 to
the q where l is the linear function
over f2 and q is a quadratic function
over f2 so this is an equivalent
representation for being a stabilizer
state
and this is through up to normalization
and from now on for the rest of the talk
i will forget about the i to the l
coefficient just to make
the notations a bit simpler
so now we choose we chose a special
basis
for
the two to the n dimensional
vector space over the complex field and
we now can
and we now can move instead of talking
about states we can talk about boolean
function or function from f2 to the n to
the complex field and we do it as
following so for every state we are
softening the boolean function we write
the state as a linear combination of our
special field
a special basis element and we and the
function
in the uh gives
in in the value of x the
the
coefficient of the corresponding vector
in the linear combination so it takes x
and and and gives f s c of x
and a stabilizer functions is a function
that is defined in the following ways so
we have the indicator function of the
sum
alpha in subspace and we multiply it by
-1 to the q where q
is a quadratic polynomial
q of x where q is a quadratic polynomial
so just to give an example what is the
boolean function associated with the the
nth power of the magic states
so
for every
um
boolean vector x the result of the
function only depends on the humming
weight of x and it is
sine of pi
pi over eight to the power of the
hamming weight of x times cosine to pi
of pi over eight
to n minus the hamming weight of x
and the stabilizer rank
of
a function
is the minimal r
such that
there are other subspaces in all
quadratics polynomial and f is a sum a
linear combination of
the r of our stabilizer functions that
are associated with those
subspace and quadratic polynomials so
yeah we we want to ask how many
stabilizer functions
are in the how what is the minimal r
such that f of h can be represented as a
sum of r
stabilizer functions its stabilizer
function is divided it is defined by an
alpha subspace and a quadratic
polynomial
um
so a similar question that only uses
this bunion analysis is
the conjecture of the quadratic
uncertainty principle
uh
so in this question we are
the conjecture is
that if you can represent the end
function
as the sum of s
a
function each of them is -1
to any quadratic polynomial
then you need at least
exponential number of summits
and so this is a very similar to
stabilize the rank but we don't have
this indicator functions of offering
subspace and indeed the stabilizer rank
of the end function is one is very small
and
this is because we can take an affine
subspace to be just a all one point
but
and another fact is when we don't we
allow linear functions in the power and
not quadratic polynomials then this is
exactly the fourier transform and then
we know that the result is exponential
because this is the fourier transform we
know that the fourier
transform of n depends on exponentially
many uh
basis elements
and the best known lower bound for the
quadratic uncertainty principle is n
over two
and it is very interesting to prove
superlinear lower bounds for any
explicit function
and
williams in 2018 showed that for every k
there is an np function that uses at
least n2 decay
summons of this sort
in its representation
so this is the
the best we know about the quadratic
associative er
principle and
the stabilizer rank is a more general
notion
so
i'll just give a two-minute idea of the
proof
so recall that we have this special
function f of h
f f h that is the following and the only
thing we need to notice about it is that
whenever we take
uh x and y that have different hamming
weights
the value of f of h on x and y are
different
okay because the function only depends
on the humming weight of the vector but
for each weight the function is indeed
different
and we want to ask what is the minimal
hours such that f of h
has such a representation
and we prove the following claim so
any function ah
f
that has stabilized the rank of at least
n
at most and over a hundred there are two
vectors x and a y and z with different
hamming weights
such that the function agree on both
vectors on both vectors and this does
not hold for our spatial function
f of h and this
immediately means
that the stabilizer rank of f of h is
at
at most
at least and over a hundred
and essentially what we proved that as i
mentioned
uh
we can only look at the
uh
we can look only at the alpha in
subspace and quadratic polynomial that
define each stabilizer function in the
com in the combination so if you have a
collection of uh at most and over a
hundred subspaces and quadratic
polynomial there is there is there are
two points
of different hamming weight
that uh in each of them all
uh all the indicator functions of the
offering subspace exist it agree so that
means that for every subspace either
both
a y and z are in the subspace or they're
both outside the assigned subspace
and the quadratic polynomial also agree
on them
and as the
the function only depends on the value
of the i identical functions and the
quadratic polynomial it means that the
computation is the same on both y and z
and thus the functions must agree so
essentially we just prove
uh the following claims if you if you
have a small enough amount of affine
subspace and quality polynomials you can
found two
points to uh points
of different humming weights on which uh
all the identicator function agree and
all the quadratic polynomials
and when we
once we do this we get we get the
uh lower bound that we needed
so let me finish the talk by introducing
some interesting open problem
so the first one is improve the lower
bounds we
gave a linear lower bound for the
stabilizer rank of the ma n stands for
power of the magic state but as we saw
as i mentioned earlier under standard
assumption this measure should be
exponential so any improvement should be
interesting
and there are two follow-up works due to
labive and lavish
lovitz and stefan
they use different technique but
again the similar lower bounds of the
same lower bounds
and
again
this question of stabilizer rank might
be similar to the notion of a quadratic
fourier analysis and the question of the
quadratic uncertainty principle
so improving the lower bound for that
problem is a very interesting
a problem from a different direction not
the quantum world but the boolean
analysis world and the uh
there is a lot to be done in this
direction also
and
can we do this the same thing as we did
here for other simulation techniques
from quantum circuits so we
used
a specific simulation technique then we
tried to prove that this won't work and
giving a large enough lower bound for
the stabilizer rank if it will indeed
prove that this simulation technique
will not work for any quantum circuit
but there are some other simulation
techniques for for what quantum circuits
so can we attack them in a similar
manner so can we prove that they won't
work for a general
circuit
thank you so much for listening and i
hope you enjoyed the talk